did a behind the scenes Skirmish lead
Stallone to stepping away from the
franchise he created here's how bad
blood and a new creative Direction kept
Rocky out of creed 3. if you haven't
been following the continuing evolution
of the rocky franchise here's a quick
recap Sylvester Stallone starred in five
Rocky films from 1976 to 1990. he
returned to the role in 2006 for Rocky
Balboa which was also the last time
Rocky Balboa fought in the ring since
then the franchise has moved on to the
next Generation zero Adonis Creed played
by Michael B Jordan Adonis is the son of
Rocky's old foe Apollo Creed and Rocky's
new Protege Jordan has starred in two of
his own films Creed from 2015 and Creed
2 from 2018 and Rocky Balboa served as
adonis's trainer both times Creed 3 is
the next installment in the series which
released in theaters on March 3rd 2023
this time around Creed has to Duke it
out with his childhood friend turned
bitter enemy Damien Dame Anderson he's
taking on this fight alone though Rocky
Balboa didn't appear in this corner for
the long-awaited frequent Jordan sat
down with IGN to talk about Creed 3 and
specifically addressed what led to
Stallone stepping away from the
character Stallone's on-screen departure
from the Creed series comes as Michael B
Jordan is ascendant as the new face of
the wider Rocky franchise Jordan sat in
the director's chair for Creed 3 which
is in keeping with tradition Stallone
directed four Rocky movies himself
Jordan said of Stallone's decision to
leave the Rocky Balboa character behind
this is a Creed franchise and we really
want to build this story and this world
around him moving forward so it's always
respect and always a ton of love for
what's Stallone built but we really want
to push and navigate if Don is forward
and the family that he created
draw everything you've found
Stallone already said on Instagram in
November 2018 that he had no plans to
play Balboa again after Creed 2. Rocky
was still alive at the end of that movie
but his health was in Decline after
Non-Hodgkin's lymphoma diagnosis the
movie also saw Rocky reconnect with his
estranged son Rocky Balboa Jr which was
a tiny endpoint for his character Arc
aside from Michael B Jordan's desire to
put the focus of the Creed franchise
more squarely on Adonis Creed it turns
out that behind the scenes circumstances
contributed to Stallone's exit as he
told The Hollywood Reporter in November
2022 he wasn't exactly Overjoyed with
the creative direction of Korean threes
Stallone said it was taken in a
direction that is quite different than I
would have taken it it's a different
philosophy I like my heroes getting beat
up but I just don't want them going into
that dark space I just feel people have
enough Darkness let me tell you
something you already know
the world ain't all sunshine and
rainbows additionally Stallone has made
it known publicly that there's bad blood
between himself and producer Ern Winkler
for years the two have been at odds over
the rights to the rocky series which
Stallone sold way back around the time
of the first film's release speaking
with Jessica Shaw of Sirius XM he shared
that the feud was a motivating factor in
him leaving the role of Rocky Balboa
behind you can't make peace when someone
has been so
so nefarious in my in my opinions losing
Rocky Balboa will surely make the rocky
franchise feel way different but Michael
B Jordan should be more than an adequate
replacement truth be told he's already
been carrying the franchise on his
strapping shoulders this time around
however the training wheels are
officially off
[Music]